two
off the rails ethan clyde is back
without his care ela off the rails
the show so off the rails were being
sued by triller
that's right
oh
you know uh
we've only been doing off the rails for
like a month or something officially and
we are already being sued by a giant
media company folks we are off the rails
here you do not want to miss a single
episode
get back on the rail
oh oh god i don't want to think about
ela when i'm off the rails
but that sound bite in there
uh today's episode is sponsored by
credit karma money canva
and upstart
thank you for funding my lawsuit
oh man so actually exciting episode
today because well i guess the white
the white is new right the brick wasn't
it wasn't there before was it
oh oh it was there yeah it was there
well my awareness yeah nice well it may
not look like it at all but we're in the
new studio this is our first episode in
the new studio we've got all the guys
here which is the first time in abs
the shredder gets all tripped out and
yeah um love the energy levels dan
you guys could step it up a little bit
guys are totally leaving me hanging here
are you can you see can they see you
guys yeah so this is the first time abs
been like working with everybody so
that's right
awesome it's been a year since we all
been together
very cool
zach's all moved into his new place oh
yeah baby big pimpin big pimpin baby
feeling good feeling amazing
friday baby friday baby coming up in two
days
i'm actually excited to announce that
we've been in talks with gabe
uh
to call in at the top of the show every
friday we're deep in negotiations with
yeah it's it's a yeah we're talking to
his agent we're finalizing the details
but you know imagine every after dark
from here on out starting with it's
friday baby yeah and that's friday baby
and that's why this is the best show on
earth nobody's got gabe calling in every
[ __ ] friday baby
friday baby yeah
and we've got a great show for you guys
here today up an amazing off the rails
experience
um before i get too deep into that i do
want to say
that my beautiful wife who is not
currently here
has a release coming out today
if you're not a member thursday at 10
a.m the color block hoodie is back let's
take a look ooh it's so crispy
it's the 2.0 with the new rib the new
fit the new uh you know embroidered
plate there on the front let's play egg
new colors
you like that neon color
it's pretty pipe in my opinion
oh you got hey and listen joe biden's
got a perfect uh pitch for you here just
go shop teddyfresh.com guess what
it crossed the economy
exactly everybody we're super excited
about this jacket
thank you joe biden is a fan of teddy
fresh and he knows how to sell it work
it boy we got this jacket we're super
stoked on corduroy
super amazing details look at that inlay
come on who does that
look at this beautiful couple with the
floral denim jacket and short hauls
short hauls ladies and gentlemen work it
work it this is the shirt yeah you ever
heard of short hauls uh not till this
moment those are overalls with shorts i
guess it's all in the name baby there
you go this guy's wearing this shirt you
know i was work okay so this is my
design i've been working on this for
like a year and for some reason this was
the hardest shirt to make but it came
out really nice
because i don't know why like his eyes
kept coming out red and it just wasn't
and then we had to like work on the
details of the shirt but anyway it's
embroidered teddy fresh
love it
thank you will
uh bags we got a lot of women's clothing
coming up uh this month kind of cool
this is kind of a new
uh
classic look i guess you would say
something we've been working on
you know some some uh
argyle sweaters come on baby kick it
with me speckled t-shirts let's go let's
go
this is all teddy fresh all the time
teddyfresh.com grow the economy today
right joe biden
love it that's gotta be one of the
hottest sound bites of 2021 already
absolutely contender it's already in the
running
i also want to i also got to flex a
little bit you know sometimes here on on
off the rails especially i'm making lots
of predictions
i was actually [ __ ] on pretty severely
for my for calling safe moon a scam
right
the subreddit was up in arms boy they
did not like that
well i'm here today to report that it's
only been like a week or two since i
just made that prediction and um
what did it lose like 50 of its value
today uh yeah i mean to be fair the
whole crypto market is crashing right
now so it's not totally exclusive to
that but um certainly anybody who who
pushed it as uh as a safe bet as the
name implies
oh good oh the good well the good news
is dave porton is in uh he's safe moon
team
is going to the moon baby
uh everybody here on the suburb that's
desperate saying don't sell
bro i think you all should sell while
you can
dave courtney 39 million shares of safe
moon
yeah and let me remind you that guy who
bought 39 million shares bought it for
200 dollars
so don't feel too bad for him
dave portney i woke up and safe moon is
down 33 now it's down i think 50 percent
but all of crypto's crashing but i mean
are they all down that much though dan
uh i don't know that much fifty percent
uh it all varies uh some of them are
though i mean it's it's a bad day it's a
it's a massacre out there right now what
am i gonna do
what am i gonna do carlos is feeling it
more than anybody
he says he's unbothered though because
i'm in it for the long haul diamond
hands anybody who says diamond hands by
the way is selling and you're the sucker
in my opinion possibly possibly you know
dave portnoy's got like 10 trillion 10
quad trillion safe moons and he's
screaming diamond hands and offloading
it all
yeah uh ethereum is down 28 right now uh
so not quite 50 but uh definitely not
good either
yeah shout out to all my diamond handers
out there i know it's hurts today
kind of inevitable that's why i just i
personally look no hate to crypto
investors and stuff but to me it's just
so volatile it's like i don't know it's
too much
too much stress in the whole crypto
market
yeah i mean you're you're the type of
guy who uh when your stock portfolio is
down like one percent in a day you start
messaging me
i mean it's true
so it's not that i've gotten better at
it yeah you have gotten better well safe
mode imagine losing 40 of your
investment in like a minute because
that's safe moon baby point zero zero
zero zero zero six
oh and then there was another one safe
galaxy was the one that really cracked
me up because uh on coindesk um you know
they didn't have enough decimal points
to even show how low it is so it's
currently it i know it's not actually
this but it's showing that it's at zero
just it's it's a it's down 50 from zero
to zero
it's literally worthless and it still
lost value
uh yeah yeah
i don't know
i don't know to me a lot of these
cryptos despite like the really big ones
i would caution all you guys
obviously you guys do what you want hey
listen me saying anything i don't
control the crypto markers don't get mad
at me
i'm just giving you my opinion
but like outside of like bitcoin and
ethereum and like a few other ones that
are really reputable and have like i
would just dude i feel like these are
all ponzi schemes where people are just
trying to trick someone else to buy
so they are they can sell it higher wait
the [ __ ] anytime you see an influencer
on twitter being like
safe moon or [ __ ] what's the new
chiba coin what was the one uh jake paul
was just pushing uh another new yummy oh
was it really yummy yeah you guys are
gonna buy yummy coin yummy coins listen
if you're if you're out there buying a
yummy coin i can't help you
i can't talk any sense into anyone out
there who's buying yummy coin on jake
paul's recommendation what about uh tits
tits coin is another great one
if you're looking to dump your life
savings into something tits coin i
highly recommend
man i saw uh elon uh tweeted this
morning that that tesla wasn't gonna be
selling their bitcoin
and within like two minutes
there were like ten thousand replies of
people mad at him because uh
well he's getting a lot of the blame for
this crash um you know maybe partially
deserved
probably not as much
as uh
not as much deserved as the amount of
hate that he's getting right now but man
that that's wild to see because you know
normally his fans are ready to sim for
him to the death but wait why are they
mad that he said he's keeping it
well because uh he was
i know he was trashing it it's not
centralized because china has it right
and he was saying he was and that you
know that the environmental impact is a
problem and all this stuff and um that
all those tweets preceded this crash and
so
whether or not that was the reason for
the crash is irrelevant uh people are
blaming him for the crash so i think it
is i think it is a result of what he
said is it his fault no because it's
inherently such a [ __ ] unstable
investment that one dude on twitter can
destabilize at 50 and it's a bad [ __ ]
investment
yeah it's not his fault i mean that's
that's the market you guys are in right
i mean also elon's the reason why it
went up so much too when he's like
tesla's buying 2 billion bitcoin so you
know live and die by the sword people
the world is not anymore the way it used
to be
i don't know
um
oh did we have this link of james
charles
the predator from this tv show
there was a tv show where they cast the
predator in it oh i got it thank you and
his name was literally james charles
it's amazing isn't it oh no what is this
from
is this like a recent show or is this
old
zack said it was scrubs right oh so it
is all it's just a weird cosmetic
coincidence i believe it is yeah i think
it's just that cause it's awesome watch
this
one belonging to a child oh no this is a
different thing scrubs no this is
definitely not scrubs yeah
it looks kind of newish it says criminal
minds oh criminal minds it's criminal
mind scrubs they're the same premises oh
here here they say 2005. so it is a
weird coincidence
but uh
in 2005 james charles was the age of his
victims but i hear there is no such
thing as a coincidence
right
there's no such thing as coincidence so
this guy was right why don't you
coordinate with the ozona coroner's
office for a match oh baby that's so
yesterday i already have the minions
working on it in the meantime
you a match to the other set in the
database his name is james charles
that's so awesome
his name is james charles
that's awesome the fact that we're
watching this means that we're all
cosmic cosmically aligned and there's no
such thing as a coincidence james
charles is a predator right
zach
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
we are cosmically aligned
um okay there's a mystery afoot when
we're moving to the new office oh i
can't even touch this
okay well here is
here is what belle sent us in the
mystery pack
the original mystery snack loves to
touch this this is outrageous daddy oh
my god
oh my god the better
so she sent us a vial of spit and it's
gone
yeah we were packing up the uh
the studio at the house
and opened that box and it's just it's
it's just gone so thick
who drank this [ __ ] i think somebody
drank it exactly
well what all right first of all why
would i drink it i was the first one to
smell it
but i refused to smell for us to drink i
didn't why why would i drink it as far
as i'm concerned that's the thing that
caused covid because we we we did a uh
make them laugh oh and then we opened it
in november
all right right before covid hit mm-hmm
and i i'm pretty sure that thing caused
covet right timing
right there's no such thing as a
coincidence that's true
dan you have a theory it sounded like
no no i don't necessarily have a theory
so you smelled in this uh
who smelled it ian actually did he
opened it you want to give a smell
review ian i wouldn't recommend it i
would not yeah he gagged
actually no it's not that bad you should
try it
it's really not that bad is it possible
it just evaporated i mean it was in
there closed and full of liquid for
years though i feel like listen i don't
want to upset anybody
but
the jar was being stored at someone's
house whose house
you know whose house
what mine yeah oh stop it and
there's only one person who had 24-hour
access to the jar
i'm not i'm not implying anything i'm
just stating facts
should i smell it yeah
off the rails let's go don't kill me
look
okay okay i'm gonna i'm gonna give it a
good smell i'm gonna i'm not gonna but
ian what prompted you to smell it anyway
you see the little top
piece yeah at first dan and i thought
that was like the spit and it was
like yeah exactly so i popped it open to
look oh it's the yeah it's like this
yeah the odor kind of blasted me a
little bit okay well let's give it a
shot shout out to belle delphine
i'm sc i'm very scared
[Music]
oh no
well so thick
what is that smell i don't even know how
to describe it i pee in my basement
i mean ian
you you were the one who smelled it yeah
that's just an opinion on it you guys
smell it take it no no no no no no no no
no no i'm good dad take it smell your
fire i'm okay take a smell there's
nothing in there on the i'll start
looking for the wrongful termination to
fire a shredder stop it
don't do it yes pass it around everybody
take away oh god it's initiation we're
christening the new office
this is belle delphine's evaporated spit
evaporated since apparently terrific
this is going to start a whole second
wave of the pandemic right yeah i know
it doesn't feel like that
well they say it's not going away anyway
oh 18 game are good job baby give it a
good whiff there describe it i really
don't want to describe it
wait hold on let me mute you be honest i
was going to play it up but that really
hit me by surprise yeah there's no
playing it up
is it like fermentation is it like yeah
it smells like biology
it's it's gonna make me throw up well
when i first smelled it
like do it dance smell it i don't know i
like spoons it smells like food here
i've also give it to zach zach
definitely drank it yeah
that's what i think too how are you
gonna go whatever that's our ages
it's gone
yeah it's all gone i know don't act
surprised
i think it did evaporate though oh it
smells like a dirty sock i kind of like
it like a [ __ ] sock
there you go you see it smells good dan
honestly i've smelled worse we got to
bury this it does it doesn't smell like
[ __ ] or anything it just smells like a
dirty sock to me it was very shocking
ian
i
oh
we love dan
we love dan that is horrific keep it on
your desk there as a keepsake i'll spit
in it and refill it for you
maybe we'll send it back to bell to
refill up with spite
so zach i wanted to get a mayo update
because
um in the last episode of after dark zak
put out a really earnest
application to be the new craft mail guy
and you feel like they've been ghosting
you a little bit a little bit uh they've
liked uh the posts but that's pretty
much it they've been reposting other
people which i feel is a total shot in
the back you know because no one's got
[ __ ] on what i did so they've been
retweeting reposting but not yours no no
public acknowledgement
they liked it though you're right
because here i'm a little bit worried
because here it says
maybe i should uh
anyway just to remind you guys zach took
a bath we set up a whole bathtub of
mayonnaise we bought like 100 with the
mayonnaise was it
and zach took a bath in it so craft
mayonnaise london real craft mail real
craft mayo yeah
not the fake craft mail no none of that
[ __ ] the fake craft mayo account
no that could be good revenge somebody
grabbed that fake craft mail love can
you get on that
like secure
security quickly just because i'm
planning because i'm planning if they're
gonna play my boy zach dirty like that
because we've already spent that ten
thousand pretty much
then we gotta go to war with real craft
mayonnaise
totally agree fake craft mail that's the
tell me if you get that love
well one thing one way i'm seeing that
they are going to be able to disqualify
you zack and i think they may have
issued this after your submission they
they very well could have well we can
tell like it it went out four days ago
today's wednesday so yeah that's after
your submission bro
but i i feel like what i did um
falls into those categories um well here
let me read it it says final reminder so
they're re-emphasizing here they saying
oh you can apply but you have to use one
of our ideas
okay
writing syncing creating art about mayo
sporting mayo fashion inventing new mayo
uses
that sounds like a nightmare what new n
what new mayo uses well i feel like
zack's uh falls into that category right
yeah he's using it to bathe right that's
a new use and then also the the art
thing i mean yoko goes and screams in a
microphone yeah what we did was a form
of performance art for sure okay
i just hope they see it that way but i i
mean i like i i see where you're coming
from how they put out that statement i
just think they're trying to carve out
carve you out yeah
that's i mean
that would really suck
out
yeah outrageous it's blasphemy in mind
i'll tell you what
i don't want to i don't want to mention
any other mayonnaise
brands here on the show
but
they're not the only game in town no
and we might have to go to war with real
craft manual did you get the account
love
no i didn't find anything
fake craft mail were you out able to ill
so
keep us updated it's probably available
yeah keep keep us updated secure that
yeah yeah grab that obviously also ethan
there they have a voting thing uh next
week well my fear is they're not even
going to put you on it because clearly
you're going to win
right that's my fear too is that they're
going to rig the primary they're going
to yeah exactly because they're stealing
it oh bro i'm telling you zach if they
steal this from you there's going to be
hell to pay
i am storming the mail headquarters
they're making a big mistake they're
making a huge mistake i'm going to storm
the capital of
they're stealing it
[Music]
yeah that that would that would suck
no we'll make sure there's justice for
zach
i mean that that would
that would really hurt you know
yeah i can tell no but you had big plans
for that 10k i mean i was like you're
gonna buy rolex you're like no i gotta
save it i gotta work towards my future
right right um but also the the thing
that really drew me was that billboard
right
well we're gonna have to get you your
own billboard i think with the craft
in the bathtub with one of the
competitors that would make my [ __ ]
yeah i think we're gonna have to do
something
if if they let somebody else win we got
to find out where the winners billboard
is and do it like across the street yeah
oh my god yeah my budget is unlimited oh
my god that would be that would be a
dream come true just saying male people
don't screw this up
oh man not screw this up
oh man
my my other fear like did you put
anything non pg in the video because i
remember i cut we cut some stuff that
was a little edgy no everything yeah no
i mean it was a man in a pool of mayo
good clean fun
what did his t-shirt say uh my concern
was his t-shirt because he had a
superman shirt i don't know if the
copyright can oh they can blur it
but i mean like if he's going to be the
face of it and they have a big blurb
shirt i guess i hope they do a reshoot
yeah yeah he's gonna have a whole
press campaign hair makeup all the whole
nine yards yeah well your legs were open
too a little bit i don't know if that's
why yeah i'm sorry that there was
moments where i was
i i i thought it was a little sexual
it's not zach's fault that he has such
raw animal magnitude and dancing covered
in damage
exactly that's all i have you tiger you
dan
well anyway don't mayo shame zach
okay i can't help them sexy well anyway
just keep an eye on these guys because i
i get the feeling they're up to
something yeah these real craft male but
guys can't be trusted i mean that that
would that would suck if it didn't
well
they're putting up the finalists they
said on june 1st so i'm not jumping i'm
going to wait till june 1st
let's see if they do the right thing
before we jump the gun here but if not
you know
oh
you know
i don't even wanna hear i don't wanna
imagine that possibility
you know
i already have too many wars going on
i can't fight a war on two fronts
anyway let's take a quick break we got
lots of good stuff coming up uh trish uh
mike uh faceblinks and mike responded to
trisha on the stream so we got the
footage and everything is gonna be
awesome
stay tuned time to take a short break oh
thank you rudy
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help even more with
credit karma money spend account you
could be rewarded for good money habits
what
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases when
you use credit karma money debit card
you can win daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to five
thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card and when you win you'll be
notified on the spot and your instant
karma cash will be added back to your
spend account
it's kind of fun you usually don't get
rewards for checking accounts or like
debit cards it's kind of dope
i get like points and [ __ ] on my credit
card but never on my debit card so it's
kind of cool
uh and you get to be a big winner at the
checkout
yeah they they've they've actually every
cashier across the country has got a
party popper
you're ready to go
they'll be notified and they'll spam it
in your face
credit karma money has already given
away three million dollars in instant
karma to over 50 000 car credit karma
members and counting
open your fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirement no overdraft fees no free or
strike that free withdrawals
that's actually kind of amazing
bro i got
[ __ ] by so many banks when i was in
college
i would have killed for this absolutely
oh bro i spent so much time like bag
like please i need that 35 dollars back
you know
such [ __ ]
not them though and i love to say that
there's no minimum balance requirement
no overdraft fees and no free
free withdrawals not no free withdrawals
you understand what i'm saying they have
free withdrawals
from a network of over 50 000 atms
credit karma money baby
progress starts here here's the quality
action listen up
visit right now creditkarma.com win
money
to open your free account and start
winning instant karma
go to
creditkarma.com slash win money to sign
up for free and start winning instant
karma that's credit karma.com
slash win money insta karma is is
sponsored by credit karma no purchase
necessary include exclusions and terms
apply c rules banking services provided
by mvb bank incorporated members fdic
maximum balance of transfer limits apply
today we are sponsored by
a
canva
you're a huge fan of canva i just found
out what is canva so canva basically
provides uh design templates for you to
create things easily youtube thumbnails
instagram posts whatever you need they
have it nice yeah you said it's free too
uh yes it's free i believe they have a
version you could pay for as well but oh
i think that's what they're doing here
sure do they have canva pro baby okay
but that's cool actually so canva is
basically just like a a
free version of photoshop
in a way yes yeah they have lots of
options presentations posters whatever
you need amazing
well let me here to tell you guys about
canva pro
if you're ready to take it to the next
level canva pro is the easy to use
design platform that has everything you
need to design like a pro if you're a
professional designer or just getting
started canva pro can help boost you and
your team's productivity and creativity
it's quick it's easy and it's affordable
i'll say unlike some other competitors
which cost
so much money so expensive is a good way
to get like
just get some professional software
you know what i'm saying because someone
some of the software out there is it's
like unreasonably expensive
they're affordable way to design
whatever you need no matter what you're
creating and sharing canva pro has
everything you need in one place
including a collection of over 75
million premium photos videos audios and
graphics
that's awesome that is honestly
really useful
it's really hard to to get like license
all that [ __ ] 75 million let's go plus
canva pro comes with time saving tools
that simplify and speed up the creative
process you get all of this and more in
just one canva pro subscription
um
what my favorite canva pro feature is
you personally i like the simplicity i
that's i have both programs the
competitors that i think you're
referring to and this is just simple i
could just pump out thumbnails or
instagram posts on the floor it's
intuitive yeah definitely i love that
sometimes i try to use some of these
like
really complex softwares and it's like
oh it just melts my brain i gotta bounce
but a canva pro it's it's it's intuitive
it's accessible you're gonna jump right
in with these amazing tools you'll be
designing like a king designed like a
pro with canva pro right now you can get
a free 45-day extended trial when you
use my promo code just go to canva.me
h3 and get a free 45-day extended trial
that's c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash h3 canva dot me slash h3
do you dread looking at your credit card
statement every month we don't blame you
and upstart can lift that weight off
your shoulders so that you can finally
feel the relief of being free of credit
card debt here's what upstart is it's
the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online if
you're using it to pay off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used up start to get
a simple fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart looks at more than
just your credit score like your income
and employment history this means they
can offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five-minute online rate
check you can see a rate up front for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
h3 that's upstart.com
h3
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you the loan amount will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
h3
we are back thank you for sticking
around
this is my favorite part of the show uh
when we're addressing faze blanks and
mike
and uh yeah mike face blanks
who's infinitely smarter than me by the
way there was a lot of chatter about my
analogy by the way on the subreddit
about my
i if i have a zero
yeah i
chatter in what way okay people were
well there was debate some people got
what i was trying to say some people
thought it was dumb
i i was just left genuinely confused
because there's infinite numbers in zero
between zero and one you can have
infinite decimal points zero is like the
state of nothing and infinite is the
state of everything don't you understand
then it's the same okay the same coin
that's what was throwing me off though
because this is [ __ ] stupid there's
an infinite shut up phase there's an
infinite number of numbers between any
two intervals it's not just that that
has nothing to do with zero oh god damn
you ruin everything i mean it's
i'm just trying to out here is nothing
right i get that okay maybe the zero to
one part doesn't make sense but like the
property of zero is undefined right it's
like infinitely nothing
yes thank you
you know
yeah okay so so you know there's some
i'm just gonna assume there's some logic
i'm just gonna assume that i'm dumb and
i'm not understanding what you're saying
no
listen the point is to i never claimed
to be smart
mike by the way has challenged me to an
iq tech an iq battle and i keep that i
do that jesus would i would i of course
not in his dreams i would do that
i wouldn't waste any time on camera with
mike
um
claim yeah no and by the way i never
claimed to be smart you know what i mean
like i didn't ever claim to be smarter
than anyone faze blanks is the one he
said he's infinitely smarter than me i'm
infinitely smarter than you and um
infinitely more successful than you
right i i i make no claim
about my intelligence or my success
face blanks
you know what i mean like uh you know
i'm not i'd do an iq test i'm sure i
would do horribly
you know
although against mike i i think i think
you have a great shot
you think i you think i have a higher iq
than mike oh totally just an update
trisha is correct it is my leg
oh there you go see see trisha knows
trisha is all he knows yeah she she is
always right that's like a meme
anyway let's watch these clips but
before we do you know fate we were
talking about how faze and mike are part
of this boys club of these kind of alpha
alpha males and so i actually have some
advice for them how they can further
enhance their alpha maleness i saw this
on tick tock and i thought about them
so um
i think
is this the music so [ __ ] up that i
don't know if it's gonna get claimed but
i'll just i'll i'll mute it so it's a
guy doing like crazy as uh push-ups here
here
yeah so here's the advice from this
video
[Music]
so stop being a [ __ ] become an alpha
now okay sleep two minutes a month work
out three months a day
sleep on the ceiling
nut in your meals it's extra protein
take shits at school
toilets with the door open to assert
dominance and only sleep with men it
boosts your testosterone
so there there's some advice for uh mike
and blanks to increase their
alpha male nurse
oh wow i really like uh take shits at
school with the door open
and just and just mad dog people
just stare at them in the eyes that's
the dominance plate right there man
that ever happened you guys were someone
shooting with the door open
yes
really yeah really both of you
immediately said yes middle eastern
people for some reason a lot of times
they leave the door open i don't know
why
are you talking about like in a public
setting or at home uh but at home but
like sometimes when there's like people
over too sometimes oh [ __ ] that's gnarly
the people will come to your house and
[ __ ] with the door open yeah i don't i
mean i don't know if that's everyone
maybe my family's just [ __ ] up so
don't get mad at me no like who no well
who in your family shouldn't with the
door open
dude one time my grandma had to open and
uh look at your grandma her dentures
were out too it was just a weird
experience i remember i was like eight
years old i still remember it yeah i
would do
my my family does the same thing that's
the kind of thing i forget wait your
parents [ __ ] with the door open my dad
and brother show the door open yeah that
done that's not okay i could see that
what [ __ ]
and your brother i mean
i can't i personally i can't do it this
is like blowing my mind i get stage
fright
you've got a door why keep it open oh
that i do i always tell him like dude
there's a door there for a reason what
is their explanation he just shits with
the door open there's no x18 it's just
like it's like it's like that line from
step brothers like we're men we make our
own beef jerky we [ __ ] with the door
open
um i disagree with that but i could
never [ __ ] at school i was always scared
i i think i went from kindergarten to
senior year of high school without ever
taking a [ __ ] at school i just really i
think so well maybe like twice in the
whole 13 years look i think we all would
like to
not [ __ ] at school but sometimes things
happen you know what is alpha though
which doesn't scare me taking a [ __ ] on
a dude's lawn right yeah right you do
which zach has done famously took a had
to pull over and take a diary on the
dude's lawn i had no choice you left it
there though i did yeah
i had no choice
you're like a terrorist you're a bio
terrorist you should be investigated
bathroom terrorist you should be
investigated by the fbi
that's a federal crime to [ __ ] on
someone's lawn
i still just don't get how they can just
not give you an answer
for the whole i think it's an outfit
i think they're dominating just like
shrug i think sorry is your brother an
alpha zach yeah yeah yeah yeah because i
know todd is an alpha he is he's got so
i think they're asserting dominance on
you zach i think you're the beta of the
family i think it's i think it's not the
act of [ __ ] with the door open but
rather the smell more wafting out
for me it's everything yeah it's
so shocking to see somebody in there
with their pants down you never show the
door open i do and it's just me and you
at home even that
even though i
don't do that for my girlfriend i don't
prefer to i close the door but like
sometimes we're in the bathroom together
and it just goes down that way i'd wait
well me and you have been together a lot
longer than you dance so maybe maybe
you'll be gifted enough to be able to
in a decade maybe i'll take a [ __ ] in
front of ali you shouldn't run alina
uh no i'm very shy
well anyway
uh faze blinks and mike definitely [ __ ]
with the door open because that's alpha
as [ __ ]
so here's faze blanks on this dude aiden
ross's stream uh addressing us
so let's enjoy this
oh this is mike
okay
so let's watch mike
let's see another thing another thing
they said too it's a little loud you can
you can you know
thank you yeah another thing they said
was um
uh they they insulted my intelligence
quite a bit and said like listen like
this they said this kid's head is filled
with hot dogs which actually i like that
joke as well there was a thank you i'm
not going to say they're not funny
but i
will happily say this
i believe in myself enough
to sit down with you ethan as well as
trisha
i challenge you to bro in your [ __ ]
dreams i don't even finish this like i
was like are you dreaming that i'm gonna
sit down take an iq test with you bozo
[ __ ] meat ground beef brain
in person iq test oh [ __ ] done by a
third party independent contractor or
someone completely unrelated to all of
us all of us
and i believe the two losing people
should donate ten thousand dollars to a
charity of the winner mike i donate
charity when i want not because i lose
to [ __ ] an iq battle to you i i
regularly donate money to charity and i
think you should too
hundreds of thousands oh i don't reflect
my generosity
i'm turning into alpha mill
mike just donate to charity if you want
to help someone i'm not sitting down and
doing an iq twice dumb ass
if mike leaned over too far ground beef
would come out of his ear
sloppy joe comes out of his ear like a
salt shaker he just gets a bun and goes
and then he's got dinner
you know what i mean
trisha if you guys are extremely smart
and the intellectual uh beauty i never
said i'm smart i just said you're a dumb
ass
two different things bruh
just if if i have an 80 iq you know you
have a 60.
he's that you claim to be i would love
to never claim that bring security you
can bring whatever you want let's sit
down let's have security because i'm
scared he's going to shove me in a
locker
right right i love that he goes you can
bring security because you're clearly
scared of my physical prowess
i'm gonna show you in a locker after i
beat you an iq test
he might make you [ __ ] your gym shorts
too yeah you're gonna bring gym shorts
mike the [ __ ] in when i beat you
have a beautiful iq test to a
third-party contractor and let's give
some money to charity i love that that's
such a great way to also also all
positive vibes ethan trisha keep getting
keep getting your bags keeping your
money but please like
try to base the [ __ ] you're saying and
at least some a bit of fact so is he
he's saying i need to research if it's
possible for a brain to made be made of
hot dog meat
remember what was the fact it was just i
guess they're they were upset the tr i
don't remember who said it i don't want
to blame trisha we were i think we
probably both said it
is that um
we said that all of them had some kind
of allegation at the table
and i guess mike oh was cross because he
said he didn't i but i don't
that is a big thing to say about
somebody if it's not true yeah i agree
you might deserve an apology for that i
mean depending on what allegations he's
talking about if the allegation is that
he has hot dog brains then that i don't
apologize
that part's true i feel like we could
prove that scientifically how about this
mike but yeah you donate a piece of your
brain and we analyze it and if they
prove it's not like uh
uh frankfurt's finest
then i donate 10 10 000 to charity
and then blanks comes on and uh here's
his take oh yeah there's a [ __ ] oh it's
so loud all right i can take jokes all
[ __ ] day i think that i think that
people are way too serious people get
offended way too easily online these
days and crack all the humor you want
phase blanks hit the phase blanks the
[ __ ] up
that's not even that bad
aiden loves it he's like
by the way he says he's he's down with
the humor and he thinks it's funny go
ahead phase
blanks
well the last time i goofed on him he
said he's infinitely smarter and
more successful than me which sounded
like a little insecure but he was in the
room with keem at the time to be fair
i think you know he's got to match that
energy the team hate death to all jews
vibes right
that's something that's funny mike said
they called him they said he looked like
a nut sack whatever
all that [ __ ] is is just humor what i
don't appreciate about them is they're
hypocrites so they'll go and say
you guys are bullying trish or someone's
being a bully any kind of criticism that
comes their way it's written off as
they're
they're bullying when they'll they'll go
on and buy the textbook definition bully
everybody else right hypocrites right
bro literally exposing how blank his
mind is
because we titled it that we're being
bullied as a joke yeah it was ironic it
was meant to be ironic dude thanks we
just thought it was funny that you're
accusing us of being bullied so we said
that you're bullying us it's literally
just a joke bruh
but that's keem that's like i don't know
why people use that's like the ultimate
insult like hypocrite
as far as crossing the line trisha mate
trisha did this like 10 [ __ ] 10 story
like thing about how me and mike are
[ __ ] old dudes starting some hype
house which
it's just
i'm sorry but on face value that is
objectively hilarious that faze
and mike are starting a content house
together
what's funny about
two men in their 30s starting a house
to live with a bunch of 18 year olds i i
understand he doesn't he goes you can
joke around just not about that that's
crossing the line
what's funny about mike who's 36 leaving
his girlfriend who's super rich and
famous and super like in love with him
who bought a house for him and then
moving in with faze blanks what's funny
about that
i challenge you to an iq test bro loser
gets shoved in a cl in a locker
and if you don't fit in the locker i'll
put you in a trash can out back
it's just laughable
what we're doing here is so much like
yeah
okay i didn't know that i didn't realize
it was much more than i passed that's
why it's ridiculous because what they're
doing is so much more than a hype house
oh well if i knew that i wouldn't have
said anything
why didn't mike just explain that to
lana
maybe she wouldn't have been pissed
this is so much more than a hype house
babe come on here give me your hot dog
bun
anyway baby it's way much more than a
pipe house
i'm sorry what was that sorry what was
that
who's hungry
sloppy joe
gotten started either that's crazy we're
just getting started now it looks crazy
hype how he's got like a curtain like
[ __ ] like
like stapled to the wall it's crazy hype
back in there
super luxurious [ __ ] bro
he missed a spot up here by the way you
might want to lock that up
so much more than a hype house alrighty
things are [ __ ] moving i know things
are going great well the vibe is good
everyone's having fun
um
right i didn't consider that
he's a good counter argument the vibe is
good and everyone's having fun
it's way more than a hype you forgot to
consider the vibe dude yeah come on let
me i'm gonna have to bring this up to
trisha
yeah i think you guys need to apologize
she didn't consider the vibe issue her
attraction here right i apologize i
should have considered the vibe i didn't
do a vibe check on the type house
but then she went on to say like
you guys are [ __ ] creepy and old and
like guys you guys have both had had
issues with underage girls in the past
yeah that pissed me off
wait did she say that issues with
underage girls i don't recall her saying
that
she probably okay
okay i mean
let's be honest i don't recall her
saying underage i think she said
you guys you guys got you guys got hyped
up quite a bit that's true we did get
excited there may have been some uh
okay so well okay let me finish this
clip and then i'll dress kind of like
what we said here
and she kept it vague whether that means
underage girls at parties whatever
whatever the [ __ ] just having your name
associated with something like that yeah
you can't do that it's disgusting i run
a business you can't base clan is my
life it takes care of [ __ ]
70 plus people
like that you know what i mean like we
have 70 plus employees and all their
families extend it out like this she's
all taken care of this [ __ ]
it's not a joke you can't just say that
and by the way i don't know if i have to
clarify this
absolutely nonsense that's never
happened everybody knows that me and
mike have never had i don't think she
said underage
i think she said they all have
allegations against them and
i will say
that um as far as
what's been publicly said
about mike and faith so i got a little
confused because i remember faze got
like a bar fight and jake paul made this
video about him that he like assaulted
his assistant or something apparently
that was proven wrong or jake said he
that it wasn't true or i don't know so
and as far as mike goes i don't think
there's any any accusations against him
other than him being a douchebag i guess
trish's thing with mike was that
he cheated on lana
and then
the girl he cheated on with he said she
looked like a gremlin
and she thought that was super trashy
like oh you're the pig that cheated on
your girlfriend you're gonna trash on
the girl you cheated on with
i think that's what trisha meant when
she said allegations but
we should be very clear and say that
as far as banks i'll be very clear i
can't speak for trisha or what she knows
but and i don't remember exactly what i
said but we were we were getting pretty
excited
and then as far as banks goes and mike
yeah so i think that's what she was
thinking of
and i will say that as far as we can
tell there are no allegations of
essay which i think is what
that seemed to be what the implication
uh that they took away so there is no
allegation in public allegations of
essay against banks or mike that we know
of other than them just being like
douchebags and womanizers which i think
is what she meant but they're right we
should be very clear about that and so i
will say here today
that if mike and banks are
guilty only of being sloppy jail brained
meathead and also douchebag womanizers
but i do apologize because we shouldn't
put that out there so you know
i think trisha meant that those
incidents but obviously when it comes
out that way we should we should be more
careful with with our words how we
express that or at least myself so
apologies to banks
apologies to mike
and um
faze up
now
that out and ricky i also told them that
like we're so like even who we have at
our house like they oh you you're the
one who literally enforced uh yo
uh this is tell
when it comes to that [ __ ] if you guys
want to come to our house like you
literally you have to pull your id they
check your age everything and i one time
i was like yeah they really seem focused
on the underage thing which i don't
remember it's funny they're focused on
the underage thing and not like just
essay which makes you like they're like
oh no we definitely essayed people just
not underage easy okay i'm kidding
that's a joke for the record okay yeah
i just said i just apologize i know
that's right but it's funny because
right
off the rails
off the rails all right
i'm kidding come on no but in all
seriousness mike and and and blanks do
not have public allegations of essay
against them i don't know what they're
talking about marriage i don't remember
that but under age or above age
so apology stem they're good dudes
obviously
you know
whether they if they [ __ ] with the door
open to alpha on people
that might that's unknown that's unknown
that's that we have not there we have
not verified those algorithms do they
jizz in their oatmeal in the morning to
increase their testosterone
yes
king kong ain't got [ __ ] on me
so there you have it
gosh i really don't remember her saying
underage but i would like to know
i'm kind of curious what she actually
said maybe he's over here watching it
right now yeah let me know what we
actually said
yeah if you could pull or just
i mean i remember when we were recording
it the the the energy uh peaked and i
wouldn't
be totally surprised if maybe things
weren't here but but i don't recall
these if you hear something specific
just relay it okay he's on that he's on
it baby's on the side actively listening
right now
interesting
so we'll check back in with a b
something else that came up on frenemies
was chrissy teigen apparently
um
this story of her
bullying this uh
uh there's like a six-year-old girl that
married a fifty-year-old man and
apparently everyone was like dunking on
this poor six-year-old girl instead of
the creepy 50 year old guy including
chrissy teigen i don't know anything
about christie's teagan but everybody
like hates her guts apparently
or well maybe now they do i didn't know
anything about her i think
after everything that went down people
do now but she was she was very popular
i mean i don't think was she
yeah i mean
she was not well liked in certain
circles because she's very outspoken
politically um so i mean you know how
that goes when you're political on the
internet but as far as like being
universally reviled
uh i think this is a new development for
her well she um is married to john
legend what a legend
got him i actually when i did hot ones
like i don't know it was a long time ago
now i remember uh sean evans asked me
about
john legend and chrissy teigen i don't
know the [ __ ] they were so that was when
i first learned their existence and i
still don't know much about either of
them to be frank he is a legend what's
uh
what's john legend's like famous song
you guys in the back now art oh yeah
it's like all of me
oh okay give me a tune oh give me a tune
zach let's hear it
[Music]
i swear to god i don't know that song
on god
i don't know who the [ __ ] they are i
really don't like they're just they've
never
i don't know how it's about here john
legend
he is a legend thank you thank you um oh
it's about oh wow two billion okay so i
should have heard this let me just give
it a little yeah i mean he's a huge
artist
oh so [ __ ] tragic he loves his wife
apparently
he's the only one left
i never heard this song
it doesn't exist
you didn't
well anyway uh the tell off of that uh
half a second of i could tell i never
heard the [ __ ] song
uh so anyway she tweeted so all this
started to come together
uh when she tweeted that she was
quitting twitter
because she was getting bullied and then
that kind of set off some people
because apparently she has a history of
being a bully she said hey for 10 years
you guys have been my world i honestly
owe you so much
i truly consider so many of my actual
friends that being said
it's time to say goodbye this no longer
serves me as positivity it serves me
negatively and i think that's the right
time to call something
so yada yada she quits twitter who gives
a [ __ ]
just exit twitter
we don't need an announcement
hi guys i am announcing today that i
will not be checking twitter for 24
hours
the reaction's like no
no we need you on twitter is she back on
twitter by the way or did she stick
through to it oh i think she came back
like a week later yeah she made it
she pulled out she pulled a quartering
she pulled a jeremy yeah well jeremy
didn't even last 24 hours right i think
she did last longer than that but yeah
that's the problem everyone who goes
every time you make this big statement
about i'm quitting twitter you look dumb
because you come back bro
you always come back to the death grip
of that blue [ __ ] bird hey twitter
world this is yours even o.j is on
twitter i mean come on
hey twitterworld anyway
so she said oh i'm being uh bullied
so then this girl
named uh
courtney is that her name yeah
bro you got to see this [ __ ] this girl
courtney came out and who was this
uh here
trying to find
here here's the clip of the of the
couple back in the day apparently this
was a big story at the time i don't
think i i don't
know hollywood's most controversial
newlyweds doug hutch she's 16.
bro that's sick yeah i mean it's not her
fault she's 16. it just goes to show how
much the times have changed like i can't
imagine looking at this and then being
mad at the girl i mean look at this
creep
i mean
this wasn't that long like you say times
change but
people should have
not okay 2011 it's saying yeah i mean in
2011 like to be blaming the 16 year old
in this relationship i think that right
that's not that long ago you're right
perhaps you remember him best as the
abusive prison guard oh perfect
that's his claim to fame
i do remember hating him in that movie
though so i guess he was good
they got all the men they need
and his wife
courtney stoddard she's an aspiring
singer and actress it's not my fault you
can't control your god oh my god believe
it or not the most stunning thing about
courtney is her provocative appearance
it's her birth certificate that's right
this girl is 16 years old so how does
that even happen her parents give
consent to maryam
or something
uh and certain uh states i mean the age
of consent is lower the 18 thing is is
not universal you know when i was a kid
i befriended there was this really weird
kid that i met on the bus but i liked
him for some reason and we started
hanging out because we live close
and his dad
he was like 50 60
and he married a [ __ ] 16 year old
and i think she was like a slow adult or
well she wasn't even adult they got
married when she was 16 and she like
wasn't all there you know what i mean
and um i was like even as a kid i i was
like how uh i was like you can do that
and he said yeah her parents gave him
consent and gave him like guardianship
over her
in
california i was like holy [ __ ] even as
a kid i was like damn
that's nuts and like that was pretty
weird you know
yep that was a weird one
uh i looked it up they got married in uh
vegas which i guess you can get you can
marry six-year-old in vegas apparently
let's go this is an article about it
vegas is wild man
van diesel
okay so we have an update from b
go ahead a b what's your update
so far trish has just said she has no
idea who faze is you know it's not like
james charles she kept going to james
charles because he was talking to minors
it's different she has no idea who phase
is so she's not going to keep going at
him
but i haven't listened to all of it but
so far phases in the clear from trisha
she did not say that he's that any of
them were dating miners so far no that's
what i'm saying she doesn't even know
who phase is but i'll keep listening
though but there is a point definitely
where she says that all three of them
have allegations yes so you'll keep
listening yes i i've heard the
allegations part
so she said that she said allegation but
she didn't say sexual allegations which
is which is a fair point i think that's
an important distinction
because
i mean
like
well okay but people know what they mean
let's not split errors here
okay all right thank you ap for the
report
um thank you
so anyway uh
yeah apparently you can marry a 16 year
old that's pretty crazy dude
so people were really like uh [ __ ]
shaming her she's 16 bro what the [ __ ]
that's crazy i don't know man yeah it i
feel like
it's pretty obvious oh here's
even here's um
anderson cooper who's like woke as [ __ ]
right so apparently he even did a really
cringy segment
about them let's listen to this in the
meantime we're just gonna have to make
do with some of their older interviews
like this one from e online
there was nothing illegal or immoral
about it it was just that we found
ourselves
falling for each other and flying on the
wings of love together you guys both
made mention a couple times about
wanting to do this uh you know
biblically morally talking about the
issue of okay i see why people are
talking about her
i mean i'm not blaming her but i see why
she's the focal
let me finish the clip but she's like
what is his face she's making
again she's 16. she doesn't look it it's
hard to it's hard to remember that she's
only 16.
was she 16 at the time of this interview
i'm fascinated by this
talk to me about the issue of what is
she doing marital sex
okay i don't want to hear the answer to
that question first of all i do however
have a few questions of my own
courtney
what makes you so enchanting
why are you so beguiling yet so elusive
what is your halloween costume gonna be
this year will it perhaps be i don't
know
something provocative
and most importantly
what the hell are you doing with your
face i have to know
all right sorry i gotta stop trying to
do comedy what the [ __ ] was that jesus
they gotta stop fast
i get it it's shocking but if i had to
prepare like a segment i would
definitely talk about what a sleazy is
and not a 16 year old who doesn't really
know how to carry yourself and you know
what i mean
no choice i i gotta see it can we please
roll my favorite clip from gma
people are welcome to their
opinions
that's what the world is about if they
if they need to feel this way dude she's
[ __ ] around is she [ __ ] around i
don't know it looks like she's on drugs
it does look like she's on drugs that
was my first thought too yeah
the mouth movements is very like mdma
bro you should be more you should
definitely be very concerned about this
guy
old not ours
oh anderson's don't do comedy brother
it's like a desperate it's like a silent
desperate i actually think [ __ ] i'm
actually really concerned for that girl
after watching that
not funny
yeah
help is what that is courtney you keep
doing that thing you do with the lips
and the weird things and the touching
the lips and the you just keep doing it
why is everybody focused on her what
about the [ __ ] weirdo dude it is so
weird he married a six-year-old he's
taking her on interviews i think he's
giving her drugs
i really do look at this need to feel
this way that's theirs to hold but she's
okay well if you thought that i mean
anderson was pretty tame look what look
what chrissy teigen said
okay you ready for this this is like
some really heinous unforgivable [ __ ]
you guys ready public tweets how old was
she when she sent this out
chrissy yeah i think we determined 26.
okay so you're 25 25 26 you're well
enough aware
to not send tweets like this to a 16
year old
and she's tagging her she says my friday
fantasy you
dirt nap
baby i'm sorry what the
me [ __ ] you you saying first of all dirt
nap i've never even said that that's
like some vile [ __ ]
chrissy is fantasizing about this girl
dying
wow
let's get out of here let's go let's
let's go have lunch
vin likes that about chrissy
she continues on
two weeks later she said go to sleep
forever and then she's asking people to
retweet that apparently
at courtney stauden on the eighth day of
christmas my true love gave to me eight
erotic elves
go to sleep forever retweet
everybody get in on these death threats
that's like the old style of uh
uh twitter
the written that eighth day of christmas
thing was the original tweet from
courtney
that's how twitter used to like do
retweets yeah
oh
so she's so cool that was her that was
her response to got it so courtney said
on the eighth day of christmas my true
love gave to me eight erotic elves
christie's response was go to sleep
forever and then she said please retweet
me
that's automatic that's automatically
the rt is the indication that it's a
retweet yeah damn chrissy that's cold
blood [ __ ]
she then tweeted at her again
directly to her what drug makes you do
that with your mouth asking for a friend
who really wants to know how to look
like an idiot
i mean
yeah
again i mean we agree that she looks
like she's on drugs but the the reaction
isn't
i would be very concerned about that old
man who's buying her drugs right
it just seems dude that guy is such a
creep and like nobody was that's so
crazy
yeah i'm sure some people were to i mean
but yeah i mean obviously there were
some people that seemed to think that
she was at fault here so
let's see what joel austin thinks
hang on what joel oh from the cube my
mind is alert my heart is receptive i
will never be the same in jesus name god
bless you is it boring
try harder joel
[Music]
cut the chanting
we're done with the chanting god be like
retweet chrissy teigen
give me the chanting zach
[Music]
god at chrissy teigen
looking forward to you taking a dirt nap
so i can take your soul for all of
eternity
whoa god tweeted that what year was how
old was god when he tweeted that super
inappropriate i thought
god wasn't
he wasn't woke yet
at chrissy teigen from god
i see your future
and you will and i can't wait for you to
die [ __ ] whoa
i call her the b word
super inappropriate
from god from jesus christ god's son
at jesus christ to chrissy tegan retweet
god i hate this [ __ ] girl
jesus
he sent her a dm apparently and said i'm
gonna nail your ass to the cross
whoa
so
i guess
holy ghost at holy ghost what is the
holy ghost i still don't know what that
mean is amen
[Music]
does anyone else the holy ghost do you
want to get into a no theological
discussion from at holy ghost
[Music]
i'll be in your closet tonight boo [ __ ]
wake up joe biden whoa
from the holy ghost the holy trinity the
whole trinity is dunking on chrissy
teigen on twitter super inappropriate
saint paul
[Music]
st paul on twitter says
i hope you get leprosy
[Music]
take a dirt nap oh my god i'm healed in
the name of jesus they're vicious
characters on twitter
chrissy teigen
from
mother teresa
[Music]
what was mother teresa and she was doing
like aids and stuff
she was doing aids she was helping
people
yeah i don't know hey at chrissy teigen
from mother teresa i'll make you suffer
more than the people that i treated with
uh leprosy oh my god i believe it brutal
self-owned from mother teresa
hey come on
from kenneth copeland on twitter
i banished kobe but i still but i really
wish i could banish you
kenneth copeland wants to banish chrissy
teigen
brutal
i'm actually uh
ironically i'm seeing that um
courtney's parents allowed her gave
consent for her to marry this dude
because
of her devout christianity
so
let's go don't ask me how that makes
sense but that's that's what it says
there you go chrissy
it's a man of god
men of god have never done anything
wrong
never
at god
from at god to chrissy tegan
i wish you grew up in a i wish you grew
up
in a catholic church i'd tell you what
the what the priest would do to you oh
so vile this has to
this is going too far from god himself
brutal
damn
apparently according to courtney
she even went as far to directly message
her saying things like i can't wait for
you to die
that's brutal dude that's almost as bad
as the [ __ ] god tweeted at chrissy i
just don't get it i mean i guess
you can't expect a logical explanation
for sending people death threats but
it's
just
why is she so mad at this girl for for
really marrying her
that's crazy
yeah she's gonna have to do some therapy
to dig into that anyway she posted an
apology but you know she's getting like
totally canceled now
funnily enough um uh chrissy made this
apology video which we'll watch in a sec
or tweet but courtney says that chrissy
blocked her and she never attempted to
apologize
since macy's has dropped her cookware
cookware
and bloomingdale's backed out of a
partnership with her
i love these celebrities cookware
oh good
chrissy taking tupperware
in that
here's her apology
i wonder if god god may issue an apology
to christie later
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
be held accountable for their past
[ __ ] in front of the entire world
i'm mortified and sad at who i used to
be
oh didn't we read this on frenemies
yeah i mean i
yeah
we did all this
i said that at the beginning
well i was just kind of been curious to
pack or unpack this whole story yeah i
mean we are going into more depth this
time um but she apologized
do you think god probably should have
paul jesus christ should apologize to
christie taking on twitter don't you
think zach
at from god
to chrissy teigen twitter
chrissy teigen
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
be held accountable for all the past
[ __ ] and trust me i've done a lot of
[ __ ]
every time a kid dies of cancer that was
me
and i'm still not sorry for all the [ __ ]
i said i hate you god god hates christy
tegan wow that's unbelievable
brutal
okay i'm done
okay thank you
me and god have that in common
oh you hate you really hate her i
[ __ ] hate her so what what is it that
you hate so much about her because this
is a new development
uh
well she's uh like i said earlier she's
very outspoken uh politically you don't
like her politics no i do not
is she conservative no
what is she she's a uh radical centrist
is probably how i would uh
those are the
she's a worst
sitter
no no no no um but uh she's
i want to see a tweet give me her most
controversial tweet i want it
well our most controversial tweet now
well okay
beside telling some poor six year old to
kill herself her second most
controversial tweet
thank you dan
um abe have having listened to that is
there any more anything more to report
so i think what they're referring to
with the underage uh whatever it was
there's some about the joke that trisha
made the orthopedic the orthopedic but
they kind of mixed the two together they
kind of took some liberties and claiming
that you guys said that so wait what
what did she actually say
um
i'm sorry i was listening to it but i
kind of had god in my other ear so give
me one second i haven't i haven't
i have the time stamp from aiden's uh
live stream
you know what did trisha say
oh does he show it yeah he's watching
he's reacting to it
so should i click this timestamp yeah
okay so here's what we actually said so
let's take some accountability here
means mouth
okay but
orthopedic
we get it bro all right that you are
everyone spin we get it
knowing that these who are like sexting
minor is like what i mean wait okay so
who's she talking about 60 miners i'm
confused
nobody's accusing them of sexing minors
right right no she's just talking about
that like the tick tockers that you've
called out yeah i don't think we i think
it was clear that we weren't accusing
them of that ortho means you're telling
me that
that phase blanks misunderstood
something
phase blanks
and conflated a bunch of other no no no
no no well let me just clarify there
could be some other thing but yeah i
mean if that's what he's referring to
that's clearly you guys were talking
about
the people that you bully
being
pedos so here's what we said we said all
three of them have allegations we
weren't specific about what kind
to clarify they do not have essay
allegations against them
right
i guess atom 22 does yeah right exactly
but i don't i don't know anything about
atom22 i haven't looked into that so i'm
not going to speak on it
okay are we good i mean you know
as a side note also uh
phase uh texted aiden during his live
and said refer to him as l3 l3 from now
on tell the chat who said that phase
banks
l3 l3 thanks why because i took the l
from hamburger brain
from hamburger helpers i guess so
okay l3l3
what that's their like nickname for you
yeah
we get it bro all right
everyone spin we get it
knowing that these i'm looking at the
chat they're chats
okay well hold on here but you guys
gotta know that we're not talking about
you guys just for clarity okay peace and
love
this is a serious message to faze blanks
and mike magelick
we did not say that you sexted miners
peace and love peace and love love
give me some chrissy teigen [ __ ] i
you're out let's just move on oh
i really don't
i don't care it's awesome that she's
getting canceled let's just leave it at
that come on don't i won't this is day
two of talking about chrissy teigen can
we just move on we got all these other
great topics
dan hit a soft spot he's soft on chrissy
teigen
it's a soft spot for dan i'm the one
saying we should move on i'm not no but
he's playing the dan the hater thing i'm
trying not to hate i'm just i'm saying
let's just move on you hate it
i see you are hating kind of
a b says he's with me
i just okay you guys are making it weird
i just wanted one political tweet but
okay i'm not gonna get i'm not gonna
deal with the full-on mutiny i just
really wanted to play that sound bite
fair enough fair enough
no that was warranted zach i'm gonna
stand by you
i'm not gonna say it
anyway let's talk about ufos there you
go let's get to the good [ __ ]
chrissy teigen have anything to do with
ufos any cross-section here
you're trying to find a segment does she
have an opinion on ufos that you don't
like
she's very opinionated she probably does
but i think she's in hiding right now so
unfortunately we're not gonna get uh her
take on the ufo situation
okay so here's the thing i know i am a
total skeptic when it comes to ufos
as in
let's be let's be clear aliens visiting
extraterrestrial life
visiting the earth
i'm very skeptical that that would has
ever happened
but
you know 60 minutes did this 60 minutes
to this report but it's it's all about
the stuff we've all already seen
and talked about
and they talked to this dude on 60
minutes
this guy here
who
i will say has an interesting look
specifically that his goatee is like way
off center
i put an album of pictures we don't we
don't want to play the clip because 60
minutes is very uh claim happy birthday
yeah
there's a there's an album of
screenshots of them if you want so
here's oh dan is just obsessed with this
guy's luck
he's
well dan do you want to i mean what
about his love it's just he's clearly a
man you can trust you think so
uh as a uh
military intelligence operator who
worked at gitmo in afghanistan he's this
is clearly a guy that you can oh yeah
there's this one part where he goes i
worked at
guantanamo bay as like credit for
military intelligence like whoa back up
aka i torture people for a living you
should listen to me dude his guilty is
so off center this is the end of his lip
and you've got like a whole stretch of
lip here
why not just trim it maybe he is the
alien
oh that would be a twist huh that beard
is kind of alien
so you're on to something yeah let's
watch this
i'm not telling you that the united
st that bother you that he worked at
guantanamo dan
they said he did military operations
there
you think he's just a dude torturing
people i mean between the lines like
he's a dude with like a wet like sponge
electrocuting people
yeah i'm not saying that for sure is
what he was doing but i'm definitely
saying that
there's a strong chance that that's what
he was up to yeah exactly zach come on
these are people
these are human beings in afghanistan
the middle east and guantanamo
he hadn't given ufos a second i would
assume that means if he's works in
intelligence that that would mean that
he works on like
identifying
prisoners to arrest and stuff i don't
know terrorists
damn no
dan's
unidentified aerial phenomena
interesting that sounds even spookier a
phenomenon
yeah i don't know why they have decided
to to ditch the maybe just because of
the stigma so i think okay so here so i
listen
60 minutes did it there's all these
clips i'm like okay i'm still skeptical
here's where i was like okay
maybe i should be more open-minded about
this
okay dan
dan the hater
obama
goes on um
on a tonight show what what is true
james corden james corden's tonight show
and this is what he says about it
uh and i'm actually being serious here
is is that uh there are
uh there's footage and records of
objects in the skies that we
don't know exactly what they are we
can't explain
how they moved
their trajectory
they did not have
an easily explainable pattern
and so
you know i think that we're
uh people still take seriously trying to
investigate and figure out what that is
uh but i have nothing to report to you
today
um
so unless i think it's interesting
because he talks about it like he knew
about this when he was president well i
mean he saw some [ __ ] they didn't
understand what he said is a very
i mean
i don't take issue with anything that he
said what he said is is pretty general i
mean sure
like a ufo doesn't mean alien a ufo
means we don't know what it is i know
that but i don't think so i think this
guy that you're goofing on with the
crooked oh
he apparently is part of like the the
ufo truther movement and everything too
and i guess he i don't think anymore but
at one point had an association with
that
whole organization that the dude from
blink182 is a part of tom delong he's a
trooper because i heard him say
something in 60 minutes i was like okay
this guy's
pretty he said something like we think
it might be like spy technology from
another country is the most likely
explanation right and yeah there there's
a whole range of explanations and then
you know obviously there are skeptics
that push back against the whole thing
and say
you know there's actually relatively
simple explanations for these things so
well again here here's my problem with
all this is like here's the photo it's
like
bro you couldn't you the u.s government
couldn't produce a higher
that's what i'm saying like because
they're still coming at us don't show me
this [ __ ] and then expect me to believe
there's aliens you got to do better yeah
carl sagan once said extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
and this my friends is a little [ __ ]
blip of tin foil it could be [ __ ] on his
windshield as far as i'm concerned right
yeah i mean obviously this is it you see
these videos in motion uh
they're a little bit more
difficult to explain that that one that
you just passed that's in the infrared i
mean when we
a couple years ago had uh the
skeptic mick west as a guest on the show
um
that video had recently came out and we
specifically talked about it and i know
that he's done a lot of investigating
into this and it it more than likely is
a type of glare on an infrared camera
and that's yeah i watched his video on
it he i mean
i'm just saying guys this is it like we
gotta get a better picture before we
start talking about aliens
yeah i mean come on this is
guys
this is not enough
but i do think it's interesting that
obama's like yeah there's [ __ ] out there
we can't and and you know he says we
can't easily explain so that is
interesting
but i have seen like all the ufo people
being like we were told we were crazy
oh yeah they're they're taking this as
well big w a big
w i don't think i ever was like i'm
i don't think aliens are visiting the
earth still i don't
i'm i think i need more
convincing evidence before i make that
giant leap
debunkers are saying about it um
lens flare oh come on it's not a lens
flare that's what they always say well
lens flare on i mean a lens flare on an
infrared camera looks very different
than oh please you're used to well it
does i mean there's that's not
reflecting an alien craft
do i need to pull up those images again
yeah it was very convincing
people are going to be mad people really
want to believe this is real trust me i
want to believe there's aliens hey i'm
all [ __ ] for i i mean i
i personally
absolutely believe that aliens are real
but believing that they're real versus
they're here currently interacting with
us are two very different statements and
the latter i don't really believe in but
the universe is an
unfathomably big place of course they're
aliens you know can i could i present a
theory like kind of going off dance um i
mean the universe is basically infinite
i mean it's unexplored
so like
like
how is it that we're the only [ __ ]
life here you know i think we all agree
that the chance of there being life in
the universe is basically a
hundred right
yeah
yeah
yes yeah i mean
[Music]
it makes sense well they also say it's a
weather balloon i dare you to argue that
dan whether balloon the fbi has been
trying to pass that [ __ ] on us since the
50s
well so speaking of which that's the
other thing is um
these
ufo
hysterics and everything
the last time that it it really was
coming up a lot was at the height of the
cold war
and um
i
do raise an eyebrow that this is
starting to happen again as we're like
kind of descending into a new cold war
against china i think it's a conspiracy
i've heard this okay so there's the the
dance theory is that it's a conspiracy
to drum up air force budget yes
and
see that's an interest that's like a
counter conspiracy right although which
i think which is
you know if you're gonna have a
conspiracy like if you're gonna get
conspiracy conspiratorial about this
whole thing the one that doesn't involve
aliens
seems like
the more likely of the two you know
whatever the likelihood that there's
someone in the government who's drumming
this up to increase budget versus
there's aliens from another like galaxy
or solar system visiting here right
the government's line as the coincidence
yeah yeah the government's lying to us
that's that's yeah if if
if if you ask me that's the more likely
explanation
and again you know the the people that
they're trotting out to talk about this
these military intelligence types i mean
this these guys it's literally their job
to lie like oh
i mean that's damn versus the united
states government
it's not really even that controversial
investment so you guys think they know
that they're telling lies for the
purpose of this secretary i think you
know maybe useful idiot maybe a lot
exactly
i have a hard time believing that guy's
a useful idiot based on his goatee
alone
he looks highly confident yes um
apparently he's a mass effect music have
so here's a little debunker for this
video this is a really famous one
that the us uh navy put out
if you look if you do very simple
trigonometry
invited by the numbers on screen
it turns out to be something far above
the surface and moving at a speed that
matches the wind at that altitude making
it almost certainly a balloon
yet the 60 minute hoax the highly
respected journalist bill whittaker
repeats
baseless claim that it's moving fast so
apparently according to this
uh that's from wic mix right yes and
again i think this specific video we
talked about when he was on the show
what things just had come in years ago
yeah it was a very recent thing so
according to him if you crunch the
numbers on the screen you can calculate
the speed that it's moving at the speed
of wind and it's because the jets moving
so fast that it appears it's moving so
fast it's like a like a parallax effect
you know
[Applause]
i think this this is the one right this
is the one that i was referring to
earlier with that uh the explanation i
guess is it's a solar flare it's an
infrared flare an infrared flare yeah
whereas the the one
previous is the one that's a balloon and
then how come it rotates because the the
camera's on a gimbal and as it rotates
it rotates it counter rotates the
rotating did look almost identical to
the plane's rotation that's that's the
thing like watch i disagree i think it's
aliens
but that's the thing that's where my
that's why my mind gets conspiratorial
it's like okay well the air force
they're not stupid why are they putting
this [ __ ] out if mick west can figure
this out then they can of course so what
so then but that's why i quote
obama who's out of office has no reason
to lie says
there were things
while i was there
that we could not easily explain
yeah but yeah i mean he's not
looking at it he's the president he gets
the briefing he gets the briefing he
knows he's just he's told what he's told
i mean he's no stuff he's not
investigating so you think obama's the
useful idiot now
i'm not saying that he's a useful idiot
but again i i didn't really even take
issue with what he said he what he said
was a very conservative statement of
there are things that
are hard to explain out there and
yeah i mean that that's fair well he
well according to mick west is very easy
to explain according to like this fast
one
yeah but i mean there's there's a bunch
of these and suppose i mean in this 60
minutes piece one of the dudes uh not
not mr goatee but another guy who was an
air force pilot or been a navy pilot
says that he saw these
things
every day for years so i mean we're
talking
like going on thousands of times well my
counter that would be like if you saw
this every day for years and i still got
no [ __ ] better image than this right
that's [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
that's [ __ ]
the government has satellites that can
get a picture of me bathing nude in my
backyard
and i can't get a picture of this shop
that's like better than a q-tip it's
kind of hard to know such thing as a
coincidence
well there's no such thing as a
coincidence that's a very good counter
argument yeah
i would love for it to be real like i i
i
you know i'm a big sci-fi guy and you
know i want aliens to be real so i'm
coming i'm not
you're a hater dude
i'm not trying to hate but
it's just
you know
okay i feel like we're being taken for a
ride with this a little bit well
apparently on june 1st the government's
putting out some kind of statement for
the first time
uh about this stuff this came as a shock
yeah so that'll be interesting i guess
the the stimulus bill last year somebody
put in some provision in that you know
two and a half trillion dollar bill
well if afo commission for some reason
are you a folk commission they said we
buy i think it's the end of june
actually i think it's i know they put up
they said june 1st it's coming out
oh so i saw that in the news okay well
so i guess we'll find out we're going to
get a commission they're also announcing
i won the craft mayo contest
oh my god that's a huge day for us on
the show big that's going to overshadow
the whole ufo june 1st is a massive day
wow
all right there's one more story i want
to talk about is these goons bryce hall
austin mcbroom please don't sue me for
showing this [ __ ] video all i'm doing
is promoting your dumb [ __ ] fight
wait is there any uh triller uh
association no i don't think so okay
thank god but i'm like dude trailer i'm
promoting your dumb fight and you're
you're trying to get people not to talk
about it imagine talking about trailer
if now that the [ __ ] trailer anyway
i feel like you know we were debating
here let me show this
no but have you ever been in like
what do you
[Music]
that's [ __ ] fuzzy yeah fousey got
somehow like he's like all into the
boxing thing now oh he made a comeback
well he he was in a boxing match and
like his face guy oh [ __ ]
that's the most brutal thing one of the
most brutal things i've ever seen yeah
you got [ __ ] fousey fought this guy
for charity and like he wasn't even
putting his hands up he had to get like
facial reconstruction and [ __ ] yeah the
announcers were like i've never seen
anything like this foosie's got to put
his hands up i got that
hopefully i don't regret saying this
because i i don't know a ton about
fousey i don't know what kind of guy he
is or anything but just
i i can't help but feel kind of sorry
for him over everything that's happening
i honestly me too i i i don't hate on
foosie like a lot of other people do
like people are so brutal oh look at
this wow
yeah
is this his uh boxing yeah
the dude literally just got punched in
the face for like five minutes straight
it was brutal it's sad in the sense
because he used to be so higher up in
youtube like well he just faked a bunch
of pranks and would never admit that he
faked them and whatever i get it but
okay he's back look he's back in the mix
um anyway we were discussing are we team
bryce or team austin
you guys are going to be surprised by my
answer
got him
go to sleep
from god go to sleep in those pajamas
you stupid [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's so planned i feel like they're they
like they probably talked on the phone
before they're like we gotta like i need
that clout you know it's total clout
it's like
jake floyd thing just a week ago yeah
that whole thing was planned too i'm
sorry
do you just like make believe i don't
know what to say bro
but we were saying well who do we favor
do we want bryce hall to win or austin
mcbroom and you know bryce hall is a
douche and we make fun of him a lot and
he wanted to fight me and stuff but
austin mcbroom is kind of
like by far a worse person stop
so for me i'm team bryce all the way
because if we remember what we talked
about austin
not only like the whole stop thing with
where he like flooded the hillside from
his pool because he's such an unaware
douche at least he did give us one of
the greatest soundbites of all time
that's true and i love the clout pill
too
what has bryce giving us
yeah we don't have much not much rice we
don't have any prices nothing there's
nothing
as far as austin goes he seems like such
a shady dude
and his first charity fight
um where he only he billed the whole
thing as this charity fight no it wasn't
a fight it was a basketball basketball
yeah yeah he built the whole thing as
this big charity event and then ended up
only donating 50 000 when he clearly
generated millions of dollars and from
what it seems to be is that like he
pocketed the money
suit one of the weirdest and shadiest
things i've ever seen in youtube history
yeah out of all the content courts that
we did that
that was the
most mind-blowing thing that we came
across uh because yeah i mean they they
it was called a charity basketball game
like the money raising was not for
charity no it was literally to enrich
them
as far as as far as i could tell i mean
wrong
yeah i
i guess we should be careful uh we don't
need a second lawsuit on our hands uh
however
from from
all publicly available
information about that event is that
they uh they pocketed the vast majority
of the money i definitely agree with
that i mean yeah we did a deeply we did
a deep research
uh just quick correction they said
they're gonna donate 100k and ended up
only donating 75k at the end so they
even lowered it and it was like a sold
out event it wasn't like they didn't
make it about the staples center
yeah so at the time we we r we crunched
the numbers and everything and yeah i
mean we estimated they made over a
million i mean easily yeah yeah
so not only that like his wife is also
in trouble right now because she put or
she put out some beauty product that's
like super low quality and everyone's
unhappy about it they're just super
shady bro they use their family they
have they literally i feel like they
have kids for clout bro i mean you're
not going to be i'm not even admits
words they have kids for content
i mean they heavily feature their kids
in their video which you know so
bryce hall it seems like infinitely the
worst dude where austin or i'm sorry
bright austin is the infinitely worse
dude bryce is just a douchebag
i don't think he's done anything other
than being a dish i need that clout so
i'm team bryce all the way i'm ready to
get i'm ready to go team bryce
i really am unfortunately based on the
skirmish i don't think bryce has a
chance
because he like charged at him and
austin like was not really fazed by it
but ultimately it's a whole [ __ ]
clown show nothing is real
yeah yeah that's the thing that's
probably all planned
i think the fight will be real but like
this is all just stage two
all right well hope you guys enjoyed our
are off the red
first ever in studio off the rails
don't sue me we should call the please
don't sue me
yeah
all right guys we'll see you on friday
oh we got an update from catherine
mcbroon his uh his wife
her skincare brand 1212 gateway why is
it called 12 gig isn't that like when
the website doesn't load
what the [ __ ] kind of name is that
it's allegedly failed to deliver
products and provide proper customer
service mind-blowing who could have seen
that coming
hmm
what is it called
i would call that uh false advertising
okay
she's off the hook
right
anyway their family is super shady
they're both of them
with that being said
we'll see you guys on friday for a first
ever in studio after dark experience
that's gonna be fun we're gonna have
gabe to christen the episode with uh
it's friday baby [ __ ] hey we're
don't over promise we're still we're
still in negotiations with gabe we'll
close it settle it's important we're
going to close the deal we're going to
look [ __ ] one of my favorite nights
all right guys thank you for watching we
will see you on friday
all right take care
[Music]
you